une loi qui permet aux lanceurs d'alert
de ne plus se sentir isolé de subir des
représailles c'est ce que nous explique
marine martin membre de l'association de
défense des victimes de la dca pin et
glenn millau membres de la maison des
lanceurs d'alert
on considère plus loin de l'être comme
une personne isolée qui du coup se
retrouve systématiquement dans une
posture de victime peut maintenant sera
accompagné par des collègues par des
associations par des syndicats pour nous
ça c'est une avancée oui on peut dire
historique mais globalement la
protection du lanceur dan r on a encore
du chemin à faire parce que comme vous
l'avez entendu la loi interdit de
licenciement les représailles mais dans
le fait il peut quand même se faire les
sorciers et obtenir des représentants
subir des représailles si j'avais eu à
disposition la maison des lanceurs
d'alerté et cette loi j'aurais pu être
aidés j'aurais pu être accompagnés et
voilà récemment 2020 j'ai été attaqué
par sanofi parce que je suis devenu une
patiente expertes et donc je m'occupe de
tout ce qui est médicaments et grossesse
l agence du médicament ils ont tenté de
me faire virer de ce poste qui me
rapporte très clairement 100 euros tous
les trois mois si j'avais eu à ce moment
là une protection juridique j'aurais pu
attaquer sanofi